[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
what up fellas what up how we doing how
we doing uh thank you guys for joining
thank you guys for tapping in we asked
you in the app and on Twitter for your
relax tonight Ryan
talk to us you are a man of the people
what are they what's some of the tweets
that you got pulled up for us not amen
of the people Greg the men of the people
V whoa whoa whoa whoa I don't know if
you can take my spot but that's okay
that's okay you you you do a good job
you do a good job maybe yeah maybe
yeah
so I can't pick and choose I can't just
cherry cherry pick which comments I want
to read here they're all on the screen
so we'll go through them here uh so in
the also in the chat right now in the
app let us know a like that you think
could rival one of these we've got etn
25 plus yards rushing can we start there
like
his number is 69 and a half like we're
starting with 25 yards rushing what is
that like minus 600 uh I don't start
with bad vibes but like I mean yeah just
bring a little something more
interesting than that
yeah we can't even do we can't we can't
even do the 25 plus yeah yeah be better
be better wow we're starting off with
hostility okay that's good to know uh
Trevor Lawrence over 12 and a half uh
rushing yards this I love this yeah yes
uh we will revisit uh Greg zurline which
we can't do over one and a half field
goals made uh not in the rain no thank
you sir uh Zay Jones anytime touchdown
and and over 100 yards receiving
wow that's a lot
okay I would I mean
that's a that's a no from me
my eyes crying right now because I don't
know I think I don't like that pig yeah
I mean
that was one I know there's some like
confu or I don't think it's fully set
like who exactly like sauce Gardner is
going to be guarding today but I would
assume it's gonna be a lot of Zay Jones
I would be careful there I know
some speculation will he be Oliver Kirk
will he be all over Zay Jones but I I
don't know I'm that's scary I don't know
if I want to even take a risk at
guessing I think I know 100 yeah 100 uh
W Moore says etn second half touchdown a
lock
um
nadus says terrible weather tonight pick
the under a lot of trig away under 39
Jay Williams under total points Michael
bowling zodovan two plus touchdowns
one whoa one touchdown is plus 155.
uh-oh Ryan is that Burberry is that
Burberry you have on uh here's the thing
man I'm really bad with knowing where I
get my clothes from I just you know what
I'm a really bad uh I'm an Instagram ad
guy so I'll see something I'll click on
it and then I'll just buy it where I get
it your dad in the comments to tell us
yeah
you guys let me know in the comments if
you guys think Ryan's shirts Burberry
we're gonna have to confirm that at the
end of the show uh but welcome to the
show welcome to the show to everybody
that is tapping in uh my name is Greg my
name is Greg next to me is the man I
like to call the man the myth the legend
but his name is Sam Richmond and next to
him is a man of the
producer Ryan we producer Ryan
no never never
make sure you guys drop your locks in
the chat we'll be grading your picks at
the end of the show right now we need
your help building a same game parlay
for Thursday Night Football Ryan tell
the people what we need
well I'll reiterate it for the people we
need your locks we need them bad
um I feel like we had two plays dropped
by Michael Boling uh and by one of the
uh the Twitter comments that I read that
I feel like making maybe debate if you
guys are cool with it uh for the first
leg here with Trevor Lawrence let's go
to his rushing yards
uh uh
all right ready 12 plus
minus 160 as a leg or we could do we're
not doing inside of a knight two plus
touchdowns that's a that's a we draw the
line in the sand at at one uh or we
could do zombie night anytime or we
could do both
what is his what is Lawrence's actual
line I know we're looking at the outline
what is his regular line oh it's getting
popped it's getting popped in real time
while you while you look up what his
actual number is I I just want to say
this and see if we're on the same page I
think that we should not do the spread
or the money line in this parlay because
no spoilers or spoilers but there are
some differing views on this game of
who's going to win so I think for the
sake of Good Vibes no spread no money
line here and we'll address our spread
money line picks in the next segment
that's a good thing I love that Sam
I'm I'm over here laughing you guys see
me laughing because I'm looking at the
comments and I like how Ryan's just not
addressing the Burberry but the furberry
that the people are calling the shirt in
the comments and you just didn't want to
talk about it not Burberry though I see
Ahmad 42 not Burberry fresh though thank
you you I of course would read that
comment what are you talking about
I'm trying to make money here Greg it's
like 20 comments saying Furby yeah we're
all trying to make money here too Ryan
we're all we're all here to make money
but uh I don't know ever since you've
been trying to get rich we haven't made
any money
Moody baby says if he doesn't know it's
not Burberry
that's a good tip yeah all right all
right all right all right let's get to
the picks man let's get to the picks
that is funny though that is funny uh
Trevor Lawrence Trevor Lawrence Ryan
should we should we look at his brushing
I mean you talked about it yeah I'm
pulling it up right now last game he had
21 game before seven game before 32 game
before 1 26 53 15 3 23 29 so he has gone
over that number a good amount and I
think where the commenter is probably
going with this is a lot of this game is
going to be played on the ground because
of yeah we should pull up a weather
report but it is going to be very windy
very cold and that uh in my expert
opinion uh leads to the game being
played on the ground right uh shout out
darian85 who uh tagged us uh in a
community post earlier on the app uh and
asked us uh about no team to score uh
three unanswered times in a row and then
I promised I would have a weather report
up
like you said Sam this this doesn't look
like friendly friendly football weather
no does not I love the weather report
Ryan
I love the weather report yeah I'm
stealing our good buddy uh Michael
Ritter's job
I think it's just uh as a theme of the
parlay we should lean on passing unders
rushing overs
you're okay with that including Trevor
Lawrence Trevor Lawrence I mean it's
it's a risky leg I you know I don't Greg
should we should we prompt the chat do a
little thumbs up thumbs down on that bad
boy yeah yeah let's let's let's do it
Sam what's the bet what do we thumbs up
and then thumbs down we looking at are
we looking at Zach Wilson over under
Trevor Lawrence Charter Lawrence Trevor
Lawrence Trevor Lawrence rushing yards
12 plus
12 plus
so for those who are betting it straight
if there's a bad beat for them and he
lands at 12. that's good news for us not
that I ruined that beats yeah but it's
what's the what's the line that though
right 12 and a half 12 and a half is the
regular line
and what's the difference between 12
plus and 12 and 15 plus what are we
doing what are we doing Greg no not 15
plus
okay okay it's delay it's delay it's
it's only a three-legger though so I
want the 12 and a half but if you want
the 12 take it take it take it are we
cool with this
yeah we're cool if the chat is cool with
it I am cool with it all right put it on
some we got some thumbs up take a deep
thumbs up D or clay thumbs up uh
um
Lawrence will get sacked all day don't
take his rushing yards Michael Jenkins
uh
that's not good vibes bad vibes 12 isn't
that much for mess Riley Lawrence under
if you're going 12 might as well go 15
that's a fat disagree for me B Thompson
I I don't I don't need another
quarterback rushing I saw exactly Wilson
that's too much passing passing yards we
didn't even add this leg
Zach Wilson
under 249 and a half at minus 600. lock
of the Year oh yeah absolutely a lot
yeah I agree with that one all right all
right all right so we want to do that
or you can or we could do 224 and a half
at minus 310. you're under Russian props
right you got to move over to the
passing no I know I'm just I'm trying to
this is a chat made poor lay and I'm
trying to see if they can give us
something and not you not push your
problem Ryan Ryan's trying to push his
propaganda that he gave to me before the
show Trevor Lawrence rushing yards we're
moving on we're moving on right
where is the truck
I mean
the chat the chat is
see the problem is is that for every
three thumbs up there's one comment that
gives me 12 thumbs down Moody babysit
Ryan Let It Go
good take
careion85 Zach rushing greater than
Lawrence rushing do you just want to go
with the 11 plus for Zach
no I don't want to bet on the
quarterback running to be honest it's a
good tip that is a fair trip I'd rather
like we're in a universal agreement with
Zach Wilson under 224 and a half yards
that's a leg in the parlay minus 310. so
hit us a thumbs up if you like that
yeah let's let's lock it in Ryan all
right we got Zach Wilson under
224.5 I I like that Sam because that's
something I'm feeling good about like
it's cold it's Zach Wilson you know what
I'm saying and and and we have the odds
on our side so I I don't know I like
this let's see if the audience likes it
sorry Ryan like we're trying to win bro
no I yeah
whatever man
whatever
you you guys chose today to fight me on
the parlay on Sunday but Sunday it was
it was so let Ryan Cook and now it's how
about how about that on Sunday though we
lost when we let you cook Ryan we lost I
know know I know a lot of Thumbs Up all
right thumbs on the Zach Wilson pick
that's that's a universal agreement okay
yeah there it is good job Sam that's one
lock there yeah
Sam with that anything anything that
stood out to you Greg anything on your
mind that that you know you've got a
scoop on
I mean I I we we we just touched it I
like the Zach Wilson under I saw
194.5 I believe but we're up to
224.5 I absolutely love this one uh let
me get back into the comments though
because this isn't our play like we tell
Ryan this isn't about me this isn't
about you Sam this isn't about this is
about the people this is about the
people uh
Travis etn Travis etn J Allen 52 says
traffic etn under
65.5 guys
let's just I mean let's just ask the
people let's ask the people let's like
you know let's ask them see under
filling it
I think he got a I think he's he's
saying under 65 and a half is that's
plus 140 at DraftKings I don't know
where he's betting on that's minus juice
can we it's it's plus money
it's yeah it's Plus 140.
and we're not in Ryan you're not trying
to get it rich
what what about the weather report where
you not understanding
it's running football weather Greg yeah
but it's like
is he really gonna get 65 yards that
here's the chat is thumbs down the Bay
Area tabs
sorry if you're a Giants fan three
thumbs down uh and bowling three thumbs
down
um
it's it's an it's a no right now Jorge
Vela I might go the other way and say
Travis etn 55 plus minus 310.
I'm just throwing that out there
55 plus
what about Donovan Knight
hi Amazon
all right
to score would be our our plus money get
rich I don't dislike that that's 155.
yeah and bowling Zano score for sure
I like that to be honest
uh Jack Sulu if the Jags were playing
the Cowboys again I'd have Travis etn
plus 150 yards rushing
that I mean
that's right
I didn't want Curry anyway
[Laughter]
the Giants fans are coping
Wilson
oh etn goes for all right
can we do it over for etn I'm okay with
doing your over that you said Sam
well then it's like
picking the legs of the parlay and I'll
get roast if it loses well you're gonna
get roasted if it loses time I don't
know like there's a fan pick of Donovan
Knight's score touchdown I'm fine with
that and you know I don't I don't have
to take blame for if it loses ah Michael
Jenkins said Donovan Knight just
practiced for the first time yesterday
since injury I did forget that he was
kind of questionable for this yeah
that's fair yeah
uh back I'll be fine with etn I do think
this game is is played on the ground
yeah
yeah B Thompson say why do that when you
can do Travis etn Touchdown for plus
135. I mean that's not bad either
there's a lot of people on Travis CTN
touchdown tonight though I don't know if
you guys saw that that information
let's let's let's let's let's ask the
people about Sam's Peak let's ask him
about Sam's pick if they like it they
sorry Sam but I I really like it I think
he can go over 55
plus territory with one more leg Yeah we
just need a plus we do need a plus money
play so that'll be my request from the
chat give us a plus money play that you
are confident in
we got a thumbs up
yeah
I mean it could be a touchdown score I
again I like Donovan Knight but there
are the injury concerns so then you
could say what about Michael Carter at
plus 310 Travis etn we could just double
up on his uh I don't like doubling up it
needs to be separate guy
cool separate guy those are the rules
on one guy that's true
he parrots vibing with you uh uh Ryan he
says uh Michael Carter anytime it's
Sneaky what if we threw in like total
sacks five plus minus 450 Zach Wilson on
the ground Trevor Lawrence little Quinn
Williams in the mix
I don't dislike
Ryan doesn't like though that's fine
says Evan Ingram anytime TD
what if we did what if we did uh yeah
and Evan Ingram
uh
Michael Carter plus 310 B Thompson a lot
a lot of commentary from the chat about
the fact that I'm I'm in a kitchen and I
have a different setup today so I love
the trip this notice of that I'm just
cooking it up
should we call you Chef is that what we
should do for the rest of the show
hat yeah and
then Evan Ingram five plus receptions I
like that that's a good take from the
chat you're a big tight end guy too Ryan
like I said get some we need to we need
a connection to tighten you just so I
can attend
we'll do like a little mini series from
tight on you uh five plus 120. I like
that I like that that gets us to Plus
320. with two legs in there that should
absolutely hit
that's not bad
wait before we do this I gotta see what
he's been doing as of late I know he's
been like scoring touchdowns uh
but has he been like has he been
receiving the ball as of late
Michael bowling is in the chat saying
that we sent an alert that this is a
five leg parlay so may we do Ingram
minus 475 3 plus and then throw two more
through two more juicers in there
bowling I get what you said we're trying
to win brother it has been too long
in fact we're definitely trying to win
what have we done before
no I like Ingram I like Ingram four plus
I mean he he he just in his last three
games eight receptions 11 receptions
five receptions so why don't we go three
there because now it's a lock and then
throw another lock in and then we'll be
at like plus 250 with four locks all
right like Jags touchdown at minus 1200
pretty pretty juicy to me
that's fair
all right okay okay so we're at three
legs we need two more
um
okay
we did two more or I'm gonna get yelled
at uh that's really what this is it's
not we don't need two more
um I need two more Jags two sacks up
minus 5.75. Zach Wilson back where do
you see that in the chat I'm in the
defensive prop section man I don't I'm
not you know not no Sam's Sam's coming
up with Scoops bro I want to know where
I want to know what Sam has in his
vision right now that his head keeps
going off of we can't see him he's I'm
looking at my iPad I got my handy dandy
iPad Greg's not the only one so I got
that off camera look into it you said
yes I got my the chat on my phone I got
I got a lot of things working man
uh should we should we go three for the
vibes
what is let's see what two does
ah
[Laughter]
you're making this too risky man we're
gonna go five lock legs we're no we
could do four lock legs okay and then
anytime TD from the chat and darien85
said we need an anytime touchdown from
one of the for one of the running backs
I like that and I think etn is probably
safer because Donovan's health is I mean
I'm down to do like
Michael Carter Michael Carter would
Michael Carter makes this
[Laughter]
story now should we ask the chat Carter
should we just has to chat to Brooke
Carter etn or night and then just yeah
nothing yep that's it
so like Garrett Wilson too but I'll
leave that out with that yeah
I really like him I think he scores
today
uh yeah I don't I don't hate that at all
uh Greg is does Garrett Wilson is
Garrett Wilson on your fantasy team
unfortunately I was gonna say I wanted
to know if that was a bias take
this is on my fantasy team
like the other four should be locks it's
like if Garrett Wilson is in the end
zone you know we're probably cashing
this puppy exactly we're winning do we
do we want to go a little bit higher on
the under of Zach Wilson's passing yards
or are we very comfortable with where we
sit like doing under 250 at minus 600
yeah
I mean I'm surprised you're the one
stressing that but I'm for it well we
already Greg and I are on the side of
don't get yelled by the fans because if
we miss we're gonna yell that you're at
the side of winning the most money
um and taking the biggest risk because
you're you're not in the the you know
the comments love you oh producer Ryan
I'm gonna you know Greg you know Greg
and I we're getting uh these guys suck
these guys are idiots all the time every
time we lose so you know well you act
like there's not a reason for that when
you're five and one on your Best Bets I
mean the chat I the chat is wealthy
because of me
it's unbelievable I feel like a
financial advisor you and your Best Bets
is that even a fact like it is a fact
I don't even remember you having a Best
Bet segment until two weeks ago
[Laughter]
six weeks man
unbelievable oh hey the funniest thing
Ryan dropped his record on Twitter and I
was gonna tweet you like bro is this a
fact like is this affect or is this just
like a riot factor I might have that
might be a reference Orion fact
Ryan fact is something that has to be
verified like it has to be uh confirmed
the fact is a fact
uh that's pretty good seven to one
seven to one right Ryan Flying Too Close
to the sun agreed agreed movie baby
I think everything else though I mean
like no Trayvon Walker for the Jacks
tonight which Rip but like I don't know
I could see Zach Wilson holding on the
ball for too long uh bad stuff happening
Evan Ingram three catches come on Travis
etn and bad weather like the only thing
I think the only thing we're gonna have
to sweat is a Garrett Wilson touchdown
I agree yeah and and darian85 just said
I don't know about the G Wilson
touchdown fellas like I like it I I like
I feel good about it but should we ask
the chat like should we just confirm
with the chat guys or how we feel it
yeah I feel like at this point that is
that is going to be the leg that the
controversial leg yes for sure I mean if
you're disagreeing with any of the other
legs
uh that's on you so I think it's just
yeah the chat you either need to say etn
Knight Carter or Wilson you got like two
minutes yeah those four names those four
names at the top
etn knight Carter Wilson you guys let us
know which way we should ride on this
parlay
and then we're gonna do it dude if you
didn't if you didn't give the double up
rule I would have been able to be talked
into Evan Ingram
I would have no too risky too risky
Christian Kirk
I just don't I don't want to touch Kirk
or Jones because I just if if sauce is
lined up against either of those guys
it's over your night is going to be
ruined because that guy is just insane
he literally might be the best
cornerback in the sport ever Ryan I'm
not gonna lie Evan Ingram
I have
I have my my little tight end Army in
here
I see him Johnny ball game Evan Ingram
TD guys come on uh
uh Dairy 85 I'm tired of sweating legs
we said locks only I'm tired of sweating
legs too man I'm tired of losing these
parlays I'll say that much wait hold on
locks only we don't say that Winners
only
uh the chat is divided there is a lot of
Ingram love and then it does seem like
there's a lot of people who don't even
want anytime TD and one another lock leg
and getting this parlay around like plus
300. yeah but there's a lot of Ingrid
love for five legs are almost 300
the cash though
yeah it's a good point I mean I can't
argue that
I mean there's a lot a lot of Ingram
love but is that the risky
I mean Sam huh
that would be hold on let's see it's a
good good note
that doesn't even do that much yeah it
doesn't even do that much
Tyler Conklin I saw
Elijah Moore's not going to get a
reception so I don't even know why
that's plus 450. uh
I am more comfortable doubling up on ATM
than I am Ingram
because I want I want a winner I want
the chat to say hey we won money these
guys are gurus rather than oh you guys
took angry I'm sure you're going safer
we would have been would have hit you
know yeah we live a different life they
called me a guru I don't know why they
don't call you all right yeah so what's
your record I guess
uh uh it's good I don't I don't yeah I
don't I don't need to say it you're not
an I Told You So guy oh no and I told
you okay
Michael Carter anytime touchdown uh from
smoke gas 420. that's it
I tell you this I tell you this if we
took this parlay is currently
constructed and tweeted out the comments
are going to be like that's kind of nice
if we tweeted out with Evan Ingram
people are gonna be like bro that's not
catchy these are the chat comments that
matter
all right let's
hey all right guys let's let's I mean
should we lock this one in should we put
our foot down Trevor Lawrence how do you
type touchdown no no
okay should we put our foot down Sam is
this Sam this is it it's not 400. no no
not Donovan
nah I mean he's hurt
it's risky yeah he's risky all right
we're locking this in we're putting the
foot down we're locking this one in Ryan
read it off for the people brother okay
uh here we go uh over 54 and a half
pressure yards for Travis etn three plus
receptions for Evan Ingram block two two
plus sacks for the Jacksonville Jaguars
[ __ ]
oh under under 249 and a half passing
yards for Zach Wilson
block
anytime touchdown Travis etn
a might hit might not we'll see
[Laughter]
yeah sure five legs uh for plus 400 odds
there it is
and there's a there's a stepped up uh
SGP boost so you know
helps us out a little bit
there it is there it is we are
did we lose something did we lose
all right oh man well I feel like this
is a better time
than ever to get in our Jets propaganda
yeah
do we want to just so yeah so that that
is the parlay of five legs oh I'm back
guys I'm back I don't know what happened
I'm back though I'm right here but
that's the parlay that's what we're
rocking with uh tell us on on DraftKings
make sure you guys tell us on DraftKings
and lock this parlay in are you guys
ready are you guys ready for our Best
Bets because that I think that's what
time it is it's time for our Best Bets
and um we're gonna do it like this I'm
gonna have Sam go first
and then Mr five and one with the
astrids next to that he's gonna go
second
and then I'm gonna round it off and then
I'm gonna go third and then we're gonna
get into uh we're gonna get into our
next segment so this is our best bet Sam
you don't have 45 seconds but take it
away brother who who you rocking with
today yeah I'm taking Jets money line
tonight to me I I really like the spot
for New York again it sucks about on
Zach Wilson I wish Mike White was in
there
um but this is just too good of a spot
you're the height for the Jags is a
little out of control what Chef Sam
that's pretty good I like that I do need
to get a chef's hat but this is just
you're you're by and low in the Jets
after a rough couple weeks you're
selling high on the Jags after some
monster wins that to me this line should
be closer to three and actually it did
end up getting there
um but bad weather gonna be handed on
the ground Jets defense will be the best
unit on the field I think they win
tonight I don't think they asked too
much of Zach Wilson I think they keep it
on the ground uh they're gonna rely on
Donovan they're gonna rely on Carter and
I think they get it done
Sam's rocking with the Jets all right
all right Ryan I just real quick we had
a take on our parlay uh from Wii Smith
44 he put not cashing Dash sorry
I thought I thought the dash sorry was
was nice thanks yeah appreciate it I
appreciate the apology
um okay
uh Sam I think you probably have to be
feeling good right about now because
you're on the same side as Mr five and
one on Best Bets right that's what I
strive for right exactly it's j-e-t-s
Jets Jets Jets money line uh all day
long
um I don't know why we don't have my
record on the bottom here with the
graphic uh that's okay
that's not true
that's a great disagree uh facts or
facts uh well that's a next week thing
when we go six and one but it's jts
chess chats uh Zach Wilson is not a part
of the reason why I feel the way that I
do I just think this Jets defense is
Elite they will run the ball down the
Jaguar's throat control the pace of the
game and win the game uh the Jets need
this win pretty bad uh they really
really really need to win to keep their
playoff hopes alive uh I think a
desperate hungry Jets team is a Jets
team you don't want to face so give me
Jets money line and I'm in the same boat
as you Sam so congrats
ones on your side all right uh you guys
locked in jet Sam locked in Jets Ryan
locked in jet so I guess it's my turn
I am rocking with
the Jacksonville Jaguars simply because
both of you guys are on the jet so I'm
going on the other side no in all
seriousness in all seriousness the way
that they battled back last week against
those cowboys just showed me that this
Jaguars team is they're fighting they're
fighting and they're gonna have to
continue to fight uh and today I feel
like I feel like they are gonna go and
to New York and put up a battle against
those Jets now the Jets
we all know who their quarterback is we
all know his struggles the the coach you
know he's trying to praise him but we we
all know who Zach Wilson is and I think
that the Jaguars can beat I mean can
reverse the trends like they're owing
four in their last uh I forget what like
in cold weather I read something like
said that they were owing for in like in
in freezing cold weather and I I know
that the temperature is going to be bad
but they're going to reverse the curse
today
you two are on the chat on the chat I'm
on the other side I'm on the other side
just throwing a little seasoning in here
it's throwing a little salt
in the in the in the chat in the in the
room
are you not worried about when you look
at this game and you look at the
elements will take away the biggest
edges that the Jags have in this game
which is Jags have a really strong
passing attack with Trevor Lawrence
who's just looked unbelievable for the
last six weeks against Zach poverty
Wilson who literally might be the worst
quarterback I've ever seen in my life
um but you you take away those edges
with the weather and then it's the game
is played on the ground and I just think
that really benefits the Jets here that
has a you have a great Point Sam but you
just mentioned the reason I'm rocking
with the Jacks the quarterback for the
Jets he hasn't impressed me Jaguars
defense has been been high it's been
decent they can get to the quarterback
and get to the quarterback
stop the run they got they got some
linebackers there that could stop the
run stuff up the run a little bit I
don't know well we're gonna we're gonna
see we're gonna see it's it's a close
game
we get side bad we can sign back we can
talk terms post shows just make sure we
could we double or nothing on the next
show of course make sure we don't learn
nothing on the next show but that's what
it is that's what it is I'm rocking with
the Jags Ryan what are uh
what are the people talking about are
they saying anything in the chat uh yeah
s Riley says I think Ryan has at least
two l's
mom
the Giants loss was maybe worth two long
uh two losses but I don't it was just
one uh DOI lamo says 2010 Jets uh if
that's the score that you're predicting
a do it correct score bet but B take the
under
um Joshua Vargas Zach is gonna fail
tonight two interceptions uh I guess we
have another question here for
um no score or yes Score first drive
I believe DraftKings is boosting 50
profit on whatever side we choose do you
guys think there will be an offensive
score on the first drive tonight
yeah I would take the no there again I
think everything about this game really
leads to it being low scoring which is
Jets have a really good defense and they
have a really bad quarterback so whoever
is on the field is going to struggle to
score
um and yeah you add in the conditions
and I will say there's a there's a smart
comment in the chat just about how much
more the wind matters and the actual
temperature and that's exactly right
it's going to be very windy tonight and
that really is what derails the passing
attack when you look at these games this
weekend not to derail the conversation
it's going to be cold everywhere but
really look at the wind because that's
that's the thing that's going to matter
it can be cold it can be snowy if it's
not windy there's going to be points but
if it's windy scoring goes way down so
pay attention to the win yeah I live 15
minutes from the stadium and I stepped
outside this morning and I went
I moved it around and the wind was too
much yeah good yeah that's what I want
to see yes so I'm going to say I'm gonna
I'm gonna say no offensive score on the
first drive tonight so
great man I'm rock I'm rocking which uh
quarterback
win elements weather
I'm rocket witch a no score on that
first drive uh whatever size you guys
are on remember you to get on DraftKings
and take advantage of
that profit boost that boost that they
got there it is you guys see it on the
screen all right man it's time to grade
some bets it's time to drop your picks
in the chat and we will grade them Ryan
what did the people like
um
David Lee says Garrett Wilson anytime
touchdown
bee
also I just want to address the comment
in the chat it says whenever something
is boosted go the opposite it's just a
profit boost you can bet whatever side
you want you can bet yes for for strap
you can bet no Score first drive so you
literally get to bet whatever you want
so get out of here with the Boost oh
everyone's against me make your pick
whatever side you want you get extra
boost on it you win some money Sam it's
the holiday season wait there's the
holiday season it is it's just the the
hostility you jumped in here with I mean
I mean it's just like they're being you
know people negative in the chat you
know it's like we're here we're trying
to be vibey don't say our bets don't do
that I'll tell you Sam I feel you here's
that here's a take that I watch I would
like you guys to grade uh Hunter small
says Zach Wilson greater than any QB in
the AFC East
okay
yeah I mean he's he's might be he
literally might be the worst quarterback
I've ever seen like in the league it is
so scary to bet on that guy but Brock
the Jets defense is so good outweighs it
but he sucks
Brock Purdy's better than that
man
uh
T-bird says Jets money Line's so free
darion85 uh dropped it in community
earlier and I'll tee this up to you guys
no team to score three unanswered times
plus 145.
that's a that's a bet uh our good friend
Bryson Stricker from the BR betting team
would love yes
um what is it yes
no is plus 145. so no team to score
three unanswered times
um
plus 145 you're throwing a bunch of big
words out there I don't know what it
means
and help me with the sale we'll play the
chat gets that laughs
two more are we getting up out here some
money to be made jervon jervon Bennett
uh Trevor Lawrence over 200 209 and a
half passing yards
go under with Craig I didn't hear the
BET
um Trevor Lawrence over 209 pass a yards
yeah Trevor Lawrence passing yards yeah
I would I would take both the
quarterback unders I I really do think
this is going to be a very low scoring
game uh Jay Loza asks who sauce covering
we do not know
um I think it's going to be Zay Jones I
think it's gonna be primarily Zay Jones
I would I but we don't we don't know but
just because
Jay Jones is usually on the outside and
that's where sauce likes to live so
we'll see
uh s Riley dvoa uh no nothing else just
dvla
um the chat a few people in the
Chatfield version reference I'm happy
about that that is like the funniest you
know wash your mouth and help me with
saying
uh doy Lemo CJ Mosley 11 plus tackles
so these are weird ones yeah that is
weird he's a baller I like the way he he
is really good roams around the field
like he's all wherever the ball is you
see his him there uh
what was it 13 11 11 plus
I don't know I honestly I like it if
they're going to be running a ball drop
in my life yeah but they're going to be
running the ball a lot a lot of tackles
that's true they'll be there uh I do
want to give one more because then Jay
loser jumped back in here after we gave
the sauce take and asked if he should
ride uh Christian Kirk props then
I'm just staying away because it it is
sort of a guessing game so I'm staying
away with overs for any I'm for the
drags passing pack in general in my
opinion I just would be very careful
there to me this is I know it's not as
fun to bet unders but to me this is a
night where in your parlays You're Gonna
Want a lot of unders or defense it you
know whether it be sacks then you can
take the over so that's just my take
cool uh I I am a man of the people so I
I want more they have they have a
question uh Phil Gango uh Trevor
Lawrence over under 12 rushing yards
all right that's our show thanks
everyone for watching
I would lean I would lean over but it
was minus 160 which is way too low we
wanted we wanted minus 500s in this way
mine is that like six and a half oh all
over that don't let the odds tell you
what a lock is let your eyes tell you
what a lock is we need that on a shirt
yeah
remember that Ryan literally remember
that quote okay thank you yes all right
bring that back up
I clip out everything I say on the show
well you're trying to get rich not that
I Told You So guy but just in case clip
clip that out and then make uh Bryson
retweet it because that that's a that's
a funny uh shirt I like that cool cool
there it is hey
let's get up let's get on up out of here
guys because it is some money to be made
tonight uh my my name is Greg Ivory next
to me is Sam Richmond next to him is
Ryan the producer Ryan that's what we
call him uh Ryan I think they want you
to go over the parlay before we get up
out of here
they love making me read on this show
it's unbelievable uh our Thursday Night
Football parlay we cooked up Zach Wilson
under 249 and a half passing yards
Travis etn over 54 and a half rushing
yards Evan Ingram three plus receptions
Jacksonville Jaguars two plus sacks and
Travis etm anytime touchdown that's five
legs that add up to plus 400 odds yes we
know it's chalky but it's a lock
there it is doesn't matter if it's
shocking and our Best Bets our best
teams it's the New York Jets Kind of
Night
yeah they're rocking with the Jets I'm
on the other side but we are part of
here y'all peace
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
yeah yeah
[Music]
this is
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign